pas tout de suite dans ce sens public à
notre second débat que nous choisissons
vous le savez volontairement décalée de
l'actualité est consacré ce soir à
l'influencé chinoise un rapport du sénat
pointe une ingérence dans nos
universités ce n'est pas le seul secteur
potentiellement à protéger ou le moigne
et
des youtuber nouveaux relais de la
propagande chinoise sur internet c'est
eux qui portent la voix de la république
populaire de chine comme ici aussi mme
zhang la province où vivent les
ouïghours une communauté persécutée par
le régime chinois
même les villages les plus reculés du xi
zhang peuvent réaliser leurs rêves et
même étudier dans les meilleures
universités du monde
en france c'est un essayiste qui est
devenu la coqueluche de la cij y
tiennent la chaîne officielle chinoise
maxime vivas conteste dans un livre les
répression subie par la communauté
ouïghoure et dénonce même une campagne
de désinformation occidentales contre le
régime communiste
des femmes ouïghours arrivé un incident
au début on leur demande est ce que vous
avez été battu le nom n'a pas été
maltraité est-ce que vous avez été
violée non pas du tout pas du tout et
puis quelques mois après elles ont été
prises emmène par des organisations
antichinoises et le discours tout à fait
différente oui j'ai été violée puis elle
pleure son éditeur les routes de la soie
entretient des liens avec le parti
communiste chinois il édite la revue
dialogue chine france en partenariat
avec une société détenue par le régime
ils font ce qu'il faut vraiment
différenciait ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier plus ou moins d'agents
d'influencé il y en a qui le font pour
des raisons financières il y en a
d'autres qui le font pour des raisons
purement idéologiques ou en tout cas
politique et ce qui est assez spécifique
je pense en france et plus largement en
europe c'est certes un individu qui
avant tout parce qu'ils veulent
critiquer les états unis un impérialisme
entre guillemets américains qu'ils
soient réels ou perçus vont chercher à
défendre en réalité les éléments de
langage de la chine mais le parti
communiste chinois compte également des
relais au plus haut sommet de l'état
jean pierre raffarin ancien premier
ministre aujourd'hui représentant
spécial du gouvernement
en chine a été décoré de la médaille de
l'amitié par le président sin jean ping
est lui aussi est mise en avant par la
chaîne officielle du régime la cij y
tiennent
le leadership
est allé chercher puissant dans un grand
pays où il faut naturellement de
l'autorité pour gouverner plus d'un
milliard 400 millions d'habitants mais
aussi pour avoir un projet qui est le
projet qui assume la légitimité du
leadership
des prises de parole dans les médias
officiels avant tout destiné à prouver
au peuple chinois que le régime compte
des soutiens dans les opinions
européennes mais la priorité pour la
chine resterait le progrès technologique
c'est notamment de capter des
technologies à l'étranger de façon
licite ou illicite et ça c'est une
constante depuis plus de trente ans de
la part de la chine selon un récent
rapport du sénat certaines entreprises
liées au parti unique aurait noué des
partenariats avec des universités
occidentales pour s'accaparer des
innovations technologiques y compris
dans le domaine militaire et les
services de renseignement nous ont dit
que en effet il avait un certain nombre
de dossiers où manifestement il ya des
entreprises par avant qu'ils avaient agi
pour le compte d'états étrangers qui
étaient venus en france pour chercher de
l'information ça c'est évident problème
pour les instituts de recherche français
trouver des partenaires de confiance
dans un pays où de nombreuses
entreprises sont noyautées par le régime
voilà et dans ce débat va se concentrer
d'abord sur la question des universités
puisque andré gattolin bonsoir en soirée
avenue vous êtes sénateur lmd des autres
c'est des hauts-de-seine vice président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense et des forces armées et
vous êtes le rapporteur de cette mission
d'information sur le thème c'est les
influences extra européennes à
l'université
j'accueille également alice heckmann
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes analyste
responsable de l'asie à l'institut des
études de sécurité de l'union européenne
votre livre rouge vif l'idéal communiste
chinois et édité au format poche de
flammarion j'ai accueilli allemand jean
paul ii chambre bon soit il serait
bienvenu vous était économiste
spécialiste de la chine et issac pas
évidemment est resté à mes côtés andré
catteau là on va détailler évidemment le
contenu du rapport on va avoir le temps
de le faire mais qu'est ce qui vous fait
dire que cette stratégie d' influence il
ya beaucoup de pays qui ont une
stratégie d'influencé la france en a une
aussi enfin oui c'est à dire qu'est ce
qui vous fait dire que dans nos
universités c'est systémique et
potentiellement dangereux est
problématique alors tous les pays digne
de ce nom une politique d' influence
souvent ça passe par l'enseignement de
la langue et de la culture
c'est du rayonnement je dirais culturel
après quand on va dans des choses qui
sont beaucoup plus fortes diffuse
notamment quand dans le monde de la
recherche on dit batten personne on ne
vous autorise pas un visa de recherche
on vous donne pas accès aux sources ou
si vous dites ça vous ne pourrez pas
voyager ou venir d'en haut on passe plus
de l' influence traditionnelle je rappel
le soft power classique on passe à
quelque chose de beaucoup plus dur et
quand des chercheurs voire même des
parlementaires se font attaquer parce
que il décide de visiter taiwan vous
savez ici on a un groupe d'étude sur
taïwan qui existe depuis de nombreuses
années on a toujours fait des voyages à
taïwan ça pose un problème maintenant
depuis deux ans on nous envoie des
lettres comminatoires houdaille on
change la doctrine il y avait une nation
de système on dit maintenant attendu
c'est une seule nation de systèmes
abbaoui hong kong et taïwan ces
capitalistes donc vers la chine
intérieure c'est son avertissement
oui c'est pour que le régime si jean
ping s'est vraiment un durcissement
c'est au sein même du parti que du parti
communiste plutôt du pouvoir chinois la
prise d'un durcissement d'un pays qui
est des plutôt défensif tout en se
développant est replié sur lui-même une
stratégie beaucoup plus conquérante
offensif on voit même sur le plan
géostratégique
je me souviens la chine n'avait pas voté
s'étaient abstenus au moment de la
résolution
des nations unies condamnant l' invasion
de la crimée est encore quelques années
la chine était très méfiante vis-à-vis
des pays qui avance et trop en dehors du
droit international aujourd'hui je pense
qu'elle est dans une autre logique
justement alice heckmann yahia il ya une
nouvelle étape dans la diplomatie
chinoise hong est loin de de l'époque
d'un sirop pays où il fallait faire
plutôt profil bas quoi un clairement oui
c'était une ping au pouvoir depuis
maintenant presque dix ans depuis 2002
la tête du parti et la présidence d'un
ping populaire de chine et on va dire
les orientations que la prison surpris
beaucoup inter de la chine tout d'abord
beaucoup de cadres du parti ont été
étonnés par notamment ce qu'on appelle
la campagne anti corruption c'est-à-dire
un recadrage qui a touché beaucoup
beaucoup de cadres du parti et de
fonctionnaires beaucoup aussi de cadres
de l'armée populaire de libération
et puis dans l'université puisqu'on
parle des universités les universités
ont été davantage supervisé par le parti
alors attention ce n'est pas un vrai un
changement de cap majeur le parti est
déjà présent au sein des universités
notamment des direction bicéphale dans
les départements de recherche avec une
validation qui était nécessaire pour
organiser une conférence internationale
pour diffuser certains livres certains
contenus en salles de classe mais cette
supervision c'est vraiment renforcée
avec une direction politique qui est
vraiment au dessus la direction
académique donc ça c'est une tendance
qu'on a vu progressivement au fil des
années et on peut dire que beaucoup de
pays dont la france avaient développé
des partenariats universitaires avant
l'appel système ping et certains ont été
un peu pris de court par la tournure
prise par le mandat de sitting ping avec
quelques années de retard finalement se
sont posé des questions sur kalou
stratégique et de sécurité sur la nature
des partenariats est ce qu'ils sont
toujours viables comment les mener tout
en défendant les intérêts des deux côtés
après il faut pas non plus de 6 et venir
sécuriser l'ensemble le du débat tous
les partenariats universitaires ne sont
pas dangereux oui mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui le monde le monde de la
recherche universitaire universitaire au
sens large en chine n'est pas du tout le
même qu'en france donc comment coopérer
avec deux systèmes on a un système très
différents qui qui fait peur souvent
lui-même à ses propos chercheur
socialiste on va y revenir je vous
entends de jean paul chanteguet ce que
vous pensez que cette menace dont don
par le sénateur gâteau n'a elle est
surévalué exagéré personnellement oui je
pense qu'il ya une sorte de bruit de
fond qui diabolise un peu la chine
depuis depuis en fait la présidence de
donald trump aux états unis qui
finalement libéré et moi et beaucoup
beaucoup de ressentiment vis-à-vis
finalement de de la chine sur plein de
plein de sujets que que soit le domaine
de concurrence économique ou financière
ou le puissance et ses erreurs la
position la posture effectivement plus
plus dure adoptée par la diplomatie
chinoise et l'évolution du régime c'est
à l'autorité de des sit-in sans arrêt
réaffirmé tout ça dans un contexte
international on voit bien que
finalement la chine aujourd'hui parler
de l'influencé de la chine il faut que
tu te voir que la chine l'a réussi à
influencer personne puisqu'elle va une
image absolument désastreuse depuis
l'ensemble des médias l'ensemble des
institutions universitaires produisent
que des textes qui sont relativement
négatif visé la chine est une sorte de
suspicion voire bas je ne sais pas il
faut se poser la question de ces c'est
simplement je pense que la chine n'a pas
manié le soft power physique accordent
peu d'importance à mon avis il croit
beaucoup plus à la réussite elle fascine
affluence était réel il y aurait passé
un peu la contamination ça je me suis
dit si c'était si dangereux ils
n'auraient pas eu l'image aussi un
disque aussi synonyme aujourd'hui dans
les médias et dans les mêmes dans les
esprits
ensuite on l'a détaillé encore non moi
je crois que l'influencé pas simplement
avoir une bonne opinion c'est aussi
amener ses partenaires ou ses
concurrents à les forcer à faire ce
qu'on a envie qu'il fasse et je crois
qu'effectivement
ce régime actuel se moque complètement
de l'image qui là parce que le silence
les tergiversations sur les enquêtes sur
les origines du coville 19 quand on voit
les les responsables de l'om est-ce
qu'ils vont enquêter con mais pendant
trois semaines en confinement qui n'ont
accès à rien qu'ils disent les données
ont disparu c'est pas ça le problème de
la chine aujourd'hui ne cherche plus à
séduire elle cherche à voir sa puissance
faire en sorte qu'elle soit il craint
donc ces occasions et chantelle mais
selon le contenu d'autres rapports sur
certains universités où certains
scientifiques français c'est avec quel
objectif c'est dans quel but abba
l'objectif c'est aujourd'hui c'est
d'être dans la conquête je dirais d'un
pouvoir global on n'est plus dans une
logique de confrontation qui avait entre
les états unis et l'urss où finalement
on avait un système d'un côté et un
système de l'autre qui était alternative
aujourd'hui la chine considère c'est son
droit que aujourd'hui de reconstruire
l'ordre mondial elle est un système
substitutif on le voit dans toutes les
institutions internationales voir les
diplomaties nouvelle qu'elle crée avec
un certain nombre d'états elle veut être
le système l' empire du milieu qui
rayonne sur l'ensemble de la planète
alice avec man est ce qu'on n'est pas là
dans une vision un peu un peu franco
française peut-être qu'on se voit un peu
trop grand est ce que la france est un
enjeu pour la chine oui c'est un enjeu
parce que c'est quand même un pays qui
siègent au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
c'est un membre majeur de l'union
européenne c'est une puissance
diplomatique la troisième puissance
diplomatiquement 20 pour plein de
raisons
qu'on pourrait mentionner à la fois
diplomatique géostratégique ce c'est un
enjeu mais mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
pas percevoir on va dire l'image de la
chine ou l'inde france de la chine
uniquement depuis paris c'est à dire que
je pense que l' influence de la chine en
tout cas les tentatives d' influence de
la chine sont réels mais les résultats
sont mitigés comme finalement on dit ou
se veut un peu ici sur le plateau de
différentes manières mais dans d'autres
pays notamment certains pays d'afrique
subsaharienne certains pays d'asie du
sud-est d'amérique latine l'influencé
beaucoup plus quand on peut le regarder
tout simplement
avec l'exemple du coc vide de
l'assistance chinoise dans le
déploiement de la politique vaccinale
aussi des tests etc c'est à dire c'était
sous ces vaccins ont été rejetés dans
par certains pays aient accepté par
d'autres de même que le projet de
nouvelle route de la soie certains pays
ont signé des accords qu'à sa nouvelle
route de la soie dont on nous ont pas
signé donc finalement aujourd'hui la
chine exaspère de plus en plus un
certain nombre de pays notamment nommé
européenne et continue à séduire
d'autres donc il n'y a plus vraiment un
combat d'image il ya un combat
d'influencé avec une promotion
d'intérêts de manière plus ou moins
efficaces même quand il ya une prise de
conscience à promotion de ses intérêts
peuvent toujours être aussi comment dire
très active parce que quand la
diplomatie chinoise aujourd'hui ses
premiers réseaux diplomatiques au monde
en son contenant d'ambassades et de
consulats des diplomates relativement
professionnel c'est l'impôt deuxième
puissance économique avec toujours une
croissance voilà significative même avec
certains ralentissements beaucoup de
facteurs qui font dire que l' influence
n'est pas venir à prendre à la légère
ces airs d'autres pays tous les pays ont
politique d' influence tous les pays qui
peuvent se le permettre mais justement
la chine a les moyens se le permettre
alors dans certains pays dont la france
parfois les éléments de langage ou et
tentatives sont tellement visible
qu'elle apparaisse contre-productif par
exemple nouvelle route de la soie les
éléments mouillage diffusée sur une
nouvelle route de la soie via des forums
ou via des phrases clés on va dire
n'imprime plus en france et par exemple
on s'est souvent l'exemple de jean
pierre raffarin mais il faut relativiser
aussi c'est pas gentil raffin qui fait
la politique étrangère de la france et
puis on peut y avoir aussi différents
communication différence revenir sur
l'épisode qu'ovide puisque vous l'avez
citer les uns et des autres c'est vrai
qu'il ya ce sentiment en tout cas c'est
ce que disait le sénateur gattolin
d'opacité tonnage total enfin je veux
dire la chine a déclaré quatre morts
commis 19 4 morts ok très bien on la
croit on la croit pas mais monsieur non
mais pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
la chine a pourquoi la chine continue et
s'enferme dans cette opacité et dans ce
mensonge parce qu'elle a aussi orchestré
des campagnes de désinformation ce qu'on
appelle des feuilles qui nous à la
manière de la propagande russe c'est à
dire que il y à un cas qui est celui de
larry romanov un pseudo scientifiques
canadiens en tout cas l'internet chinois
l'a encensé comme étant un scientifique
mondialement reconnue qui aurait
enseigné dans cette université
prestigieuse de shanghai et puis quand
on a cherché un petit peu on sait on a
découvert enfin on jeudi on mais c'est
quand même un site de recherche
stratégique de l'école militaire qui a
découvert que cet homme existe m étais
n'était absolument pas scientifique
il a vaguement fait un peu d'import
export et puis il était surtout
complotistes et il écrivait n'importe
quoi sur la pandémie et la chine l'inde
et fait part de sa biographie c'est
d'avoir été arrêté pour trafic de
timbres en 1995 elle est servie mais
vraiment en employant mois par point les
méthodes du kgb en 1983 qui avait dit
que le sida venaient des états unis est
bien là la chine a employé les mêmes
méthodes pour dire le virus du coc vide
19 ou de lakovic et plus comme on dit
viens d'une base militaire des
etats-unis donc vous voyez bien que la
chine est quand même au coeur aussi
d'une guerre d'information parce qu'il
me semble quand même que l'image est
fondamental aujourd'hui dans notre
société notamment dans cette guerre
d'influencé
il faut dire que historiquement en
france la chine a eu à bénéficier de
capital sympathie très fort très fort à
droite à travers le gaullisme puisque
c'est en 64 que la france reconnaît on
un des premiers pays à reconnaître la
république populaire de chine parce que
quelque part de gaulle était une sorte
de non-alignés sans l'être refusant le
commandement intégré de l'otan et puis
de la gauche qui voyait le contre modèle
je vous parle pas de 68 ch puis pas le
même mode et des partis traditionnels de
gauche qui voyait un contre modèle au
stalinisme et ça ça perdure encore
aujourd'hui et j'ai des collègues qui me
disent ah bah nous on était content de
voir arriver des chinois et nous
proposait dans nos collectivités locales
des développements un mirifique un des
échecs aujourd'hui dans les classes
dirigeantes économique et politique
c'est que les promesses n'ont pas été
tenues club allemand moi j'ai des tas
d'amis qui ont été responsables de
département qui met on avait des projets
mirifiques et qui ne sont jamais arrivés
il ya eu que le dixième c'est le même
problème qui a dans le reste de l'europe
avec tout le système 16 +5 17%
aujourd'hui les pays de l'est entre
guillemets 10 or on nous a promis
beaucoup on n'a pas vu arriver grand
chose par contre a commencé à nous dire
qu'est ce qu'on devait faire jean paul
chang vous nous écoutez calmement et en
préparant les missions j'ai vu 18
souvent qu'on est un peu parano
vis-à-vis de la chine plus je trouve
formidable je pars donc réjoui son
formidable j'ai pas ou qui sont fort
hills mais j'ai dit qu'on peut très bien
être neuvizy laudatif ni j'aime dire
systématiquement dépréciateur je crois
que ce qui est important ce n'est pas de
mettre l'idéologie c'est précisément en
tête c'est que si les relations
internationales la diplomatie non plus
que l'idéologie nous sommes les
meilleurs nous sommes nous des valeurs
les bonnes valeurs et les autres c'est
vraiment le diable le magistrat cheikh
la diplomatie n'a plus de sens et les
relations internationales risquent de
devenir extrêmement explosive ce que je
veux dire je pense moi personnellement
que cette période ou leed j ai donc en
tête deux ans de coheed où les gens se
fréquentent plus doués h même plus on va
nous plus les collègues universitaires
s'offre un zoom éventuellement quoi j'ai
avant tout ça fait que le club le fossé
se creuse et donc en fait on a
l'impression que ça va durer et que ça
mais personnellement je pense que c'est
quand même très temporaire je pense que
c'est temporaire parce que c'est pas
possible des différentes nations et
différents pays y compris pour l'europe
et pour la france un moment donné c'est
nos intérêts réels qui vont qui vont
être de l'enjeu il ya quand même des
grands groupes français qui les plus
grands goût français avaient voulu
successfull si on me dise dire à la
bourse de paris si l'on d'édition des
parts de marché gigantesque la chine
s'est pas seulement la grande usine du
monde c'est aussi le plus grand marché
aujourd'hui dimanche alors je vois que
les américains a continué je vois aussi
que les américains continuent à investir
en chine
l'ancien patron de goldman sachs se
continue à fréquenter vidéo géant
chinois c'est tout le problème pour la
politique ça comptera la politique
puisque la marche et économique à une
telle opportunité c'est vrai que c'est
difficile après d'avoir une ferme et ses
environs pendant une position du un peu
un peu j'ai un peu plus sereine dire que
je ne participerai pas à une sorte d
hystérisation de qualification de
l'autre en ennemis ou en danger et en
menace parce que je trouve que c'est
contre nos intérêts à long terme via il
ya un élément
vous allez monsieur henry j -c le
passage l'interview du ministre du
commerce extérieur que je voudrais
entendre dans quelques secondes c'est
effectivement franck riester qui est au
coeur de cette problématique que vous
êtes en train de me poser et voilà la
chine c'est à la fois un concurrent est
un partenaire économique et il est
évidemment prudent franck riester quand
il parle de gâchis dans l' écoute ce que
nous ne refuserons toujours c'est une
logique de confrontation avec la chine
est ce que ceux qui songent à 100 dans
tout ça c'est le risque de d'escaladé
militaire dans la région nous voulons
engager si je puis dire les la chine
d'une façon exigeante dans une compet
compétition exigeante et on sait bien en
matière commerciale la concurrence
parfois déloyale que met en place les
chinois vis-à-vis des européens les
inacceptable et pour autant on pense que
la logique de blocs la logique de kazim
guerre froide est une mauvaise logique
dans laquelle nous serons bien est
français on ne veut pas se joindre andré
gattolin qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
cette réaction oh vous savez quand on
est ministre du commerce et commerce
extérieur effectivement c'est
extrêmement important mais pour revenir
d'une manière plus générale moi je
trouve le point de rupture c'est hong
kong hong kong la chine étaient liés
devant la communauté internationale
auprès des britanniques sur un statut
d'eau rétrocession et d'un accord signé
traité jusqu'en 2047 et loi de sécurité
nationale loi sur la réforme électorale
qui cassent complètement le traité par
ailleurs la chine avait signé le fameux
la fameuse convention sur les traités de
genève de 69 qui fait qu'on ne peut pas
remettre en cause un accord sur des
points avant son terme sur des points où
on n'a pas mis des réserves on a une
double rupture du respect des règles
internationales
tout ça s'est fait sous le silence et je
pense qu'en partie une des réactions des
américains savoir le sentiment d'avoir
laissé passer ça alors il ya un sur
discours sur taïwan sa chute d'accord on
va pas aller à la troisième guerre
mondiale à cause de taiwan mais
je dirais le pouvoir et ce notamment si
jean ping s'est on a redit de d'une
certaine manière de de cette réussite
qu'il a eu sur hong kong parce que
finalement la communauté internationale
y compris les britanniques est la brique
site pendant des mois et des années
n'ont rien n'y a fait alors on va
revenir quand même au contenu de votre
rapport et à cette notion de stratégie
d' influence avec style au jour d'un
rebond soir steve bienvenue donc ce ce
rapport du sénat qui consacre cette
stratégie d'influencé peut-être on peut
revenir à la définition c'est quoi une
stratégie d'influencé une stratégie
systémique qui frôle l'ingérence à ce
que c'est ce que vous écrivez andré
gattolin de votre dans votre rapport
alors vous avez organisé une trentaine
d'auditions vous avez interrogé les
ententes tablissements d'enseignement
supérieur français vous avez aussi
étendue vos investigations à d'autres
pays que la france conclusion il existe
selon vous et bien deux manière
d'influencer les états étrangers tout
d'abord le façonnage de la réputation
d'un état par la promotion d'un narratif
ou par l'instrumentalisation des
sciences humaines deuxième manière la
captation de données scientifiques
sensible dans les deux cas vous
considérer qu'il s'agit d'un risque
majeur pour le pays visité la chine
est-ce que c'est l'état qui est le plus
en mesure de conduire cette stratégie
systémique c'est en tout cas ce que ce
que vous écrivez un andré gattolin même
si vous évoquez évidemment les
stratégies russes ou encore les
stratégies turcs mais les moyens mis en
oeuvre par la chine pour sa politique d'
influents sont sans commune mesure selon
vous avec celles des autres pays alors
comment la stratégie chinoise se traduit
en pratique en france ça passe notamment
par l'implantation à la multiplication
des instituts confucius dans l'hexagone
vous en parlais tout à l'heure je crois
on compte 17 instituts de ce type
aujourd'hui sur le territoire des
instituts et bien qu'ils sont chargés
officiellement en tout cas de promouvoir
la culture et la langue chinoise mais
ces instituts sont souvent directement
intégré à l'intérieur de nos
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
ils ont souvent un programme ils ont un
agenda politique et comme on dit entrée
6 qui est qu'on dit parfois bien à
l'autocensure des enseignants notamment
en ce qui concerne la situation par
exemple à taïwan autre outil d'
influence de la chine ce qu'on appelle
le front uni alors ça date de presque un
siècle c'est un peu compliqué à
expliquer il s'agit en fait d'un organe
rattaché directement au parti communiste
en chine le front uni c'est à prévenir
la dissidence politique à l'étranger
donc en france vient le front uni est un
outil de contrôle de la diaspora
contrôle qui passe notamment par des
pressions qui sont exercées sur les
étudiants chinois est alors quelles sont
les solutions préconisées pour lutter
contre cette rallonge en a vingt six 26
à
toutes les fermes peut-être quelques
unes parmi ces recommandations on peut
citer notamment la création d'un
observatoire des influences étrangères
on trouve aussi le la nécessité de
renforcer la protection juridique des
activités universitaires et puis enfin
vous demander d'agir pour davantage de
transparence au sein de l'université
merci steve pour tous ces détails en
andré gattolin renforcer la la
protection juridique des activités
universitaires ça pourrait passer par
quoi bein notamment on a un certain
nombre de chercheurs qui se trouve
aujourd'hui attaquée dès lors qu'ils
sont pas fonctionnaires ils n'ont pas la
protection fonctionnelle on a eu une
chercheuse une sinologue qui a fait
l'objet d' attaque elle devait payer
seuls les procès qui lui était intentée
ça c'est une chose et puis c'est aussi
signalé ce qui se passe c'est à dire
qu'on est quand même dans un monde un
petit peu du silence lorsque j'ai fait
mes auditions il y avait des
représentants d'universités où il y
avait des instituts confucius une des
responsables après avoir témoigné en
visioconférence donc ouverte s'est
retrouvée
admonestée par ses collègues en dix ans
mais pourquoi tu as des parlers tu
comprends les chinois c'est important
nous avons des échanges ça va pas leur
plaire tu aurais mieux fait de rien dire
directrice enfin patronne d'université
nous parler on voit la carte des 17
voilà mais les instituts confucius pour
moi c'est pas le principal problème
c'est le soft power old school de la
chine d'avancer jean ping aujourd'hui
c'est jean ping c'est les programmes de
talence et envoyer des gens vous savez
quand il ya un programme qui a créé en
c'est ça oui elle trouve à mille talents
mais aujourd'hui il n'existe plus il ya
dix mille autres mais consiste à
proposer un universitaire chercheur
devenez faire des cures d'être salarié
et peu à peu on se rend compte qu'il ya
un
pardon mais abbaoui nommé ça ça on a une
responsabilité mais pendant longtemps la
chine n'avait rien apprendre ont donné
tout s'était creusée en termes de
coopération la france était un des pays
les plus ouverts vis-à-vis de la chine
aujourd'hui ils se retrouvent en
compétition moi j'ai un ami qui est
industriel en suisse et qui est un d une
des sociétés de nouvelles technologies
les plus importantes il est allé en
chine en 2000 il a développé son
business il m'a dit à partir de
l'arrivée de saint jean ping je me suis
fait prendre toutes mes données j'ai
tous fermés j'ai tout rapatrier en
europe c'est à dire que c'est très
difficile de garder votre ça va faire
votre propriété intellectuelle vos
contenus si vous ne pouvez pas acheter
entre guillemets l'université vous
achetez un chercheur jean paul chang est
ce que ce régime est beaucoup plus
offensif dans parce que c'est pas
nouveau effectivement là la guerre
économique où la chasse aux talents
écoutez moi je le pense savoir que c'est
un comportement de pays puissants donc
avec une industrie forte et une finance
forte un développement important je
pense aux etats unis le nombre des
talents européens ou même mondiaux qui
partent aux états unis chaque année et
on parle pas de l'affluence américaine
ou d' ingérence américaine mais non
européennes à je veux dire qu'on parle
que de la chine de la chine de régime
je pense à cliquer pour parler c'est un
peu facile si vous voulez de toujours
dire que nos problèmes vous avez pointé
le doigt sur il faut payer mieux nos
universitaires non protégés bien entendu
il faut faire ça mais de là à toujours
trouver un ennemi extérieur pour
justifier de nos faiblesses je trouve
cela pénible deuxième chose les
problèmes de deux influences ingérence
qui était avec des sous-entendus jean le
front uni la diaspora chinoise celui
dont le rapport etc je les entends du
jeu le fond et nice ça n'existe pas
monsieur non mais que c'est pas un
organe démocratique et non sélection
dans le rapport sur ce que ckac sports a
chinoises oui je signale je sais plus
quel jeu j'espère qu'il ya déposé ici ma
filiation qui a parlé d'exploration en
disant qu' il faut ils veulent
influencer identi.ca prix dangereuse
pour le régime chinois quelques pas et
derrière ça se transforme en une sorte
de sous-entendus c'est presque la
cinquième colonne qui risque
effectivement de déranger notre sécurité
et c'est tout je trouve qu'il ya un
petit côté péril jaune là dedans et pour
tout dire je reçois ce sera un peu comme
du racisme anti jaune écoutez ma femme
est asiatique alors ne parlez pas de
péril jaune j'ai veillé précisément
qu'on ne doit pas parler de la diaspora
de manière univoque en disant c'est la
cinquième colonne nom précisément il ya
aussi une volonté mais les turcs font la
même chose vis-à-vis de la population
turque qui résident en france parce
qu'ils sont confrontés à un autre régime
et ça les inquiète qui est des
influences à l'intérieur de la
population c'est aussi ça le contrôle de
la diaspora c'est pas la même chose des
gens qui viennent étudier
de manière décidée organisé dans une
université avec parfois des objectifs
qui dépasse celui sympec d'études qu'une
population locale qui elle même peut
être parfois sous pression de l'état
d'origine parce qu on dit ces gens sont
trouvées pourraient prendre des
habitudes démocratiques qui sont pas à
nos normes à nouveau revenu sur
l'idéologie mais ce que je veux dire ce
qu'ils ont une ingérence il faut qu'il y
ait comme des faits d' ingérence en
gérant ses skis sont ils se sont
ingérées dans nos élections et ce qu'ils
sont
ray dans la législation dans le rapport
parlementaire est ce que c'est quoi là
je sais quoi de l'ingérence ça continue
précis dit oui à l'ingérence qu'on les
arrête nous bouffe à ses procès qu'on
délivre les âges mais c'est facile de le
jeter un doute une suspicion comme ça
parce que forcément forcément je vais
dire ça rejaillit sur toute une partie
de la population et pour moi si vous
voulez c'est une façon en échange vu des
réactions comme ça dans d'autres pays
que soit produit de l'origine commune et
c'est que le nombre d'incidents anti
asiatique que ce sont des pluies
démultiplier dans certains pays
notamment anglo saxons et donc je pense
qu'il faut faire attention quand on
compte quand ça veut dire alors demandé
à 7 à cette
demande d'aidé preuve d'ingérence donc
sur restons sur la question de
l'université formelle et des dépressions
il y en a moi je sais pas parler
d'ingérence je parte d'influents les
pressions ena perpétuellement pendant
des années 2 je suis parlementaire
maintenant depuis plus de dix ans bien
que je publiais un papier sur le tibet
et cetera j'avais où je faisais une
déclaration j'avais une plainte qui
était posée auprès du ministère des
affaires étrangères à une personne qui
reçoit les plaintes ce qui est tout à
fait normal aujourd'hui on accuse les
parlementaires de ne pas obéir aux
ordres de l'état et on dit à l'état vous
parlementaires disent des choses ils
veulent aller à taïwan ils ont dit ça
c'est pas bien écouté j'ai essayé de
monter il ya six ans un colloque ici sur
l'europe et la chine avec des chercheurs
d'origine chinoise qui vivait à londres
qui travaillait dans une très grande
université pour pas la cacher la london
school of economics
mais qui n'étaient pas des gens affiliés
au régime qui travaillaient sur la chine
qui connaissait j'ai vu tout mon
parterre d'invités
disparaître quand j'ai essayé de
comprendre pourquoi tous les gens
annulait j'ai eu un des chercheurs il
m'a dit j'ai été con j'ai été convoqué
par ma direction en me disant que les
fondations chinoise donné 300 mille
livres par an à cette université et que
si j allais 7 à mes risques et périls et
notamment ma chère été payés par set par
set
cette dotation ça s'appelle de l'
influence je pense qu'on est dans un
pays libre où les gens doivent pouvoir
s'exprimer librement c'est le vin dit
qu'il manque d'argent dans la recherche
je suis le premier à le dire depuis des
vitres et mais quelle qu'elles quel
regard vous portez d'arbitrer au moi
j'ai j'analyse la fine que je connais
presque mieux que la france mieux que la
france on peut aussi
clairement les chercheurs chinois
aujourd'hui c'est eux les premières
victimes chercheurs les étudiants qui
sont les premières victimes du
durcissement des conditions de travail
dans le monde de la recherche
concrètement un chercheur chinois
aujourd'hui à beaucoup plus de
difficultés voire l'impossibilité de
quitter le pays pour effectuer un
terrain de recherche sur la france par
exemple quand il est spécialiste de
l'europe de la france de le faire avec
un camarade et avec un responsable on va
dire du parti ou ou en tout cas de la
ligne du département de liaison
internationale de sa structure
éloigner les contraintes très fortes
dans l'exercice de leur métier par
exemple pour organiser une conférence
internationale ils vont devoir avoir le
jeu vous intéresse que vous devez partir
en séance je souhaitais revenir
ça s'appelle du direct
s'il n'y a pas de souci c'est tout près
à l'hémicycle et l'a donc vous n'avez
pas bien loin à l'est merci beaucoup
merci pardon nous avons bien fait ceci
donc oui le monde de la recherche a
évolué en chine il est beaucoup plus
contre ans est une réalité ils sont
contraints dans leurs échanges
internationaux donc nous quand nous
sommes contactés pour une conférence
internationale au quand on a justement à
faire des choix sur le type de
partenariat quelles institutions
chinoises de quelle manière bien sûr ce
sont une nouvelle question qui se pose
puisque le contexte chine n'est pas le
même qu'il ya dix ans donc la façon dont
on travaille et la façon et changer la
façon dont de concéder une conférence
comment conjointe mais pas la même bien
sûr les échanges doit continuer à
exister parce que nous sommes voilà
nous sommes dans un monde interconnecté
et même tout simplement pour comprendre
la chine en tant que chercheuse sur la
chine on a besoin d'échanger des
chercheurs chinois il faut pas être naïf
sur l'exercice de leurs fonctions alors
qu'ils sont en train là elles ne sont
pas les mêmes que les nôtres donc dans
ce contexte là ils ne pourront pas
répondre la même façon aux questions qui
leur sont posées il rond pourront pas se
dépasser de la même manière et pareil
pour les étudiants de plus en plus donc
ça c'est quand même une question et sans
généraliser selon 110 étudiants chinois
mais les conditions sont plus les mêmes
par exemple une question toute simple
comment éviter que les étudiants chinois
s'espionnent entre dans les universités
françaises c'est tout simple tout le
monde n'est pas un espion et voilà mais
comment un étudiant chinois peut tout
simplement étudié à la française en
france c'est à dire librement et
s'exprimer librement ça justement
monsieur en fait je voulais juste
connaître votre définition du régime
politique chinois comment on pourrait le
définir
comment ça
je sais pas ce que c'est un régime
autoritaire est ce que c'est un gym
démocratique est ce que c'est une
dictature est ce que ces voiliers ces
différents régimes politiques comment
vous pourriez le définir c'est le
produit de l'histoire politique de la
chine effectivement c'est à la suite
d'une d'une victoire militaire en 1949
avec un parti communiste chinois qui la
prétention d'incarner effectivement la
renaissance de la nation chinoise car
côté nationaliste et tous qu'ils ont
leur propre système de choix de la
dirigeante de la politique c'est ils ont
leur façon de délibérer entre de trouver
des compromis etc c'est pour nous un de
nos points de vue effectivement ces
régimes qui est autoritaire qui est
centralisé qui n'est pas mais de là à
dire que y'a rien à étudier de près à
mon avis ce serait une grande erreur
parce que pour lui ce qui est important
si les échanges ça fait deux ans que les
échanges sont plutôt court en ce moment
moi ce que je crains le plus c'est que
s'ils allaient y aller il ya des
barrières supplémentaires dans les
échanges universitaires pas avec crainte
du type que ceux ci tu as passé dans les
années
ce que j'ai un peu peur c'est qu'à un
moment donné si on décroche complètement
sur la connaissance de la chine j'ai lu
un article dans le washington post
les services de renseignement américains
ils se sont réunis et ses atouts ils se
plaignent de ne plus avoir de
spécialistes la chine et ils connaissent
plus les processus de décision de ce qui
se passe en chine évidemment si vous
passez votre temps à être militant et à
lancer des slogans tout ça vous ne
pouvez pas établir éventuellement des
contacts et avoir à apprendre comment ça
fonctionne et c'est ça vous dire que si
les conseils que la conséquence
notamment du mandat de donald trump je
pense qu'il a une sorte de hystérisation
delà du thème idéologique est ce que moi
je préfère effectivement c'est quand
même qu'on peut revenir un peu comme
avant il ya des choses qui sont dues au
contexte chinois comme liszt avis très
très très justement en difficulté pour
les chercheurs chinois d'être plus
libres etc ils sont dans le contexte qui
est un peu hostile aussi par rapport au
monde extérieur ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'elle s'étend de nos intérêts de
continuer à avoir essayé de revenir sur
les contacts mais on peut vivre ainsi
mais aussi de mieux comprendre ce qui se
passe parce qu'autrement on aura une
génération de gens qui ne comprend rien
à ce qui se passe là bas qui on va
simplement
mais je pense quand même que dans
l'historique de vous dire des événements
les premières barrières aux échanges
deviennent quand même de pékin il faut
le dire aujourd'hui pour leurs
chercheurs pour leurs institutions donc
dans ce contexte là oui il est difficile
aujourd'hui de dialoguer d'échanger
est
en effet une idéologisation du débat
mais elle n'est pas déconnecté c'est à
dire que l'idée aux gestions de la
diplomatie réel nous sommes dans des
tensions que je considère de type bien
froid toutes proportions gardées c'est à
dire que en chine il ya un discours anti
occidental très fort au sein du parti je
parle pas dans sa population mais le
parti quand même des points à un
discours anti occidental où tous les
occidentaux seraient beaucoup seraient
les forces hostiles anti chinoises dont
il faut se méfier
et ce serait vrai de tous les médias
américains de tout quoi faire sur
l'opinion publique bien sûr et donc dans
ce contexte là il est normal ensuite que
ce discours politique rejaillissent
dents au sein d'une partie on va dire de
la recherche d'une accalmie chinois qui
essayent notamment de parfois de faire
bonne figure dans un contexte difficile
et aussi dans la comtesse de tensions
sino-américaines renforcer et donc je ne
sais pas où une destination du débat qui
est déconnecté laisser dirons nous
sommes dans une diplomatie qui reflète
des tensions idéologiques très forte
voilà alors enfin actuellement et on ne
serait ce que de décrypter l'existence
de cet ancien logique c'est déjà je
pense en premier le travail des
chercheurs et nous sommes c'est pas près
de se calmer de mon point de vue merci
beaucoup merci
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat et je remercie aussi sénateur
catholique a dû partir en séance il
devait parler je crois juste avant le
premier ministre que c'était très
important de filet il nous avait
prévenus quand même avant le début du
débat il nous a pas pris en traître je
train je tiens à le dire mais je
rappelle le titre de votre livre alice
heckmann c'est rouge vif l'idéal
communiste chinois et ses ré édité au
format poche de flammarion 2